Sham referendums in occupied regions of
Ukraine and more Russian troops are
drafted into battle but the protests are
increasing across the country
my guest this week had his own unique
protest Paris bandario a Foreign Service
veteran resigned in shame at the war in
Ukraine the only Russian government
official to do so in public what are the
chances of Putin surviving the conflict
he started he put himself in the
education where he has no good exism I
think this black male and threats is the
only instrument he may use to try to get
himself out of it as the war goes on how
real is the nuclear threat and why do
Russian officials believe the West
wouldn't retaliate against the nuclear
strike from Moscow
[Music]
welcome to conflict Zone hello team
before we talk about your personal story
I'd like to deal with some of the latest
events going on in the Russia Ukraine
war
um let's start with the so-called
referendums the taking place in four
Ukrainian regions occupied by Russian
troops asking people if they want to
join Russia itself since no one is going
to believe the result why bother with
this
um I think it's only for like domestic
consumption to convince people within
Russia that it is all right and those
people in this new created republics are
really wishing to join Mother Russia so
it it is it is giving President Putin
and her government a good you know
reason to to continue to continue the
work
in order to defend the people of tambas
of the parisia of persona region and so
on so it's beautifully for a domestic
cancer domestic population and you think
the domestic population is that gullible
that they're going to believe it they
know by now that Russia doesn't hold
elections unless it fixes them in
advance does it
well you know the Russian population
which is the main problem is it has been
so far very indifferent to what is going
on outside so to speak so it's only
these days some of them are starting to
understand that the war is much closer
than it was than they thought it was and
so yeah I think the uh the government is
still believing that if they can sell
any anything any stupid things to the to
the people even now
we've seen in the last few days utter
chaos over the partial mobilization
which Putin ordered the Kremlin says
it's drafting 300 000 troops to Ukraine
other Reports say around a million how
much difference do you think these extra
troops will make because the failures so
far haven't been caused by troop
shortages have they they've been caused
by low morale poor Logistics weapons
that haven't worked poor command
structures that's been the problem
hasn't it
um yeah I guess so and uh I believe that
these new numbers even if they come all
at once to the front line they will not
change the course of War they will can
only make it more slow for Russia to to
to lose the war
because the Russian army has been
has been so far very incompetent in
terms of strategy in terms of military
planning in terms of implementing of
military operations and so forth so so
on so for now the main
superiority if I may say so of the
Russian army uh in comparison with
Ukrainian who was the numbers the
numbers so I think they can only fight
with numbers well one of your most
powerful criticisms of the Russian
government that you served is that it's
part of a system that deceives itself
is that the military's problem as well
it's been deceiving itself about its
capabilities about its weapons the state
of its preparedness this kind of thing
yeah sure sure this this picture is
absolutely common for all branches of
Russian government
it is all built on these lies and cells
uh so self self comforting reports and
so on so we can see it by the decision
of Putin to invade Ukraine in the first
place it's obviously that he
miscalculated his own strength and the
ability of Ukrainian Army and the
reaction of the West it was all a great
misrecordation based on misinformation
he received from uh from Minister of
Foreign Affairs from intelligent service
from minister of defense and so on
but do Russian officials even know where
the truth really lies anymore
well it's hard to say that because I
think on the very low level people who
work really in the field so to speak
they know the truth but while the truth
is being reported from down to up
it is distorted in many ways so it's no
surprise that the decision makers on the
upper end of the chain they have the
information which is not which not
reflecting reality in full
over the 20 years that you worked in the
foreign Ministry you said the level of
lies and unprofessionalism was
increasing all the time is that what was
demanded by the bosses just tell the
Kremlin what they want to hear
that's it yeah yes yes because if you
report to to Moscow the the situation
and the residuation is not always
favorable to us they may think that you
you don't work well enough and it will
make your career prospects less radiant
than you could expect so everybody wants
to please Moscow
to show that they working very hard and
then you can count to some career
promotions and also that's that's it
that's purely career oriented thing you
said in May that you had recently seen
misleading information cabled to Moscow
because that's what they wanted to hear
what was that information
um
mostly it was that the Russia Russian
interest or Russian positions regarding
the world uh is a very widely shared by
many countries but Russia is not
isolated that the Western accusations
are false and everybody understands that
they're false for instance it also goes
to the chemical
scandals about these three piles
poisoning on a whining poisoning for
instance and some other things so
um it is you know this uh reports and
it's a very sophisticated thing when you
when you have to report truth but you
have to disguise it so nobody
understands that it is an unpleasant
truth
yeah it's a kind of art you see but this
is really very very bad kind of art you
you're very scathing about the foreign
minister Sergey lavrov did you expect
better from him
um you you say he symptomized the
degradation of the system
um well well he he he he he he he
has done a lot of evolution from the
very prominent and uh hopeful minister
to what we are seeing now he's just
another symbol of this degradation of
this system which is now uh denying the
reality
so I don't expect anything from him and
anything from the government he
represents and I think that it will we
will we will see very soon the collapse
of the system
really collapse
yes based on what all the lies that
they've told they suddenly realize that
nothing is true that everything's going
wrong and there's nothing there and it's
too late to do anything about it is that
is that the scenario that you foresee
I foresee that it is all it of course
depends on the war and its outcome but I
don't see how Russia can Prevail and can
achieve a real Victory on this
this can be achieved only if the Western
countries stop supplying and supporting
Ukraine at all and if the West
surrenders to Putin well so to speak
that's the only way Putin can be aware
in all other scenarios you will have to
retreat he will have to back down and
then it will be very very hard blow to
this regime
in the run-up to The Invasion when
Russian diplomats all over the world
were ridiculing the idea of war did you
know that Putin was going to invade the
U.S knew about it last Autumn and said
so did you know did people in your
Embassy know this was going to happen
no well it was
the the information for the decision on
invasion was not of course disclosed to
almost anyone
so it was only personal uh guessing
whether he will decide to invade or not
I personally didn't believe because I
would foresee all these consequences
that this Invasion would would have and
I I was pretty sure that Moscow also has
this knowledge had this understanding
but evidently they they didn't evidently
they must populated everything as I said
so Moscow lied to its own embassies as
well as to everyone else
I wouldn't say they lie they just don't
tell anything that they don't want to to
tell it they the embassy adjust their
auxiliary thing for them
you said what Disturbed you most in the
uh Russian Embassy was the Casual way
some of your fellow diplomats talked
about nuclear strikes against the West
even though they worked in Arms Control
did they have no idea how these nuclear
strikes that they were talking about
might lead to World War III or the
consequences of that
um you know these very dangerous thing
is that those people who who are
boasting about this possibility to to
make new strikes against the West
against the United States in the first
place
those people are sure that there will be
no regulation
that the West will just swallow it and
just bend the knees and let's say let's
Okay okay we're scared we're scared okay
let's let's make this negotiations
they really believe that what what makes
them believe that
I think it's a very old and common uh
Prejudice regarding the westerners in
Russia that the Western people are very
weak and very pampered because they are
very used to comfortable life you know
and that they are not ready to sacrifice
it like for the war because every war
makes makes people makes people's life
uneasy and the difficult and we passions
we are known to all the world that we
can suffer for as long as it takes well
it's another Prejudice of course
but people may share it and the people
who may take decisions they also may
share this with you
at one point you asked your former
colleagues if they'd be happy for their
children to live in radioactive ruins
and they simply replied this is about
values traditional Russian values as
opposed to those of the decadent West so
in their minds it's okay to blow up the
West if the West doesn't share these
wonderful Russian values
um that's I think that's because it's
all these talk about imaginary things
because no one can really imagine what
will be what the nuclear war will be and
of course they just try to uh to make
themselves more confident about that
but
I believe that some decisions can be
made on this wrong wrong grounds
unfortunately
in the last few days we've heard more
threats from Mr Putin more unrest across
Russia itself some commentaries have
suggested that amid all this chaos
Putin's power is beginning to drain away
do you buy that
scenario
um
I think that these events and
demobilization are arranged by Putin is
another symptom of his uh yeah of his of
his Decay your decay of his regime
because it's the last resort apart from
the nuclear weapon nuclear blackmail
that he may he may use so we see this
unrest in the in the in the regions
different regions and so I I can't
exclude that those unrest and some
turmoil will be uh will be rising in the
coming days how long can you make as
many mistakes and chalk up as many
failures as he has and remain in power
these days in Russia
um it's it's hard to say it's hard to
say I think the fate of gujan's regime
is
strongly dependent on the outcome of the
war of only force of the world we've
already seen that this hierarchical
Society very successful for Ukrainian
did make a blow on the reputation of the
Russian army Russian government even
within the supporters
so if he he will continue and I hope he
will continue getting uh defeats from
the Korean army that will will derail
his reputation his Charisma and the
killers of this regime I guess my
question is more about the the Hardline
political and security Elites in Moscow
they're not exactly known for having a
forgiving nature how much of this how
much more of this will they put up with
do you think I mean we've got a long
list of failures we have the failure to
take Kiev the failure to arrest zelenski
the failure to hold on to territory that
they'd captured High casualties Hardware
that doesn't work poor morale
um he has to Putin has to be running out
of political Capital at home doesn't he
well well he has well he has we cannot
judge because we don't have any
information it's a very closed thing but
there is no doubt that the Russian
Elites are split now and a lot of them
want to to change something or to jump
off
but I think the the for now the most
powerful figures around him which can
command you know Armed Forces special
services they're still uh sticking to
him
for some reasons maybe they still
believe that Putin can resolve the
situation like Hitler's generals some of
them were very loyal to humanity very
young for instance so all they just can
cannot have enough imagination to think
about the future without putting and
themselves without power so it's very
difficult to predict but it's
it's natural that there will be more
splits and we will I think we will see
something
Maybe by by New Year
if you strip away all the the lies the
accusations the propaganda do you in
your own mind have a clear idea why
Putin started this war
yeah he started this war because he
wants to stay in power he wants to
secure his throne for Lifetime
and since he cannot sell to his
electorate to his population any
economic successes because the economy
is shrinking it is going down since 2014
the in the daily life of most people in
Russia has been deteriorating steadily
he can only sell some military successes
that's why he wanted to conquer Ukraine
because it
it would have given him this Aura of
like of a great Russian ruler who uh
defends Russian interest and so on it
then would work for some years like it
worked with Crimea he just wanted to
repeat this Crimean exercise
so this idea that he felt threatened by
NATO and he thought NATO countries were
trying to encircle Russia although how
you encircle a country that has 11 time
zones and is 10 or 11 percent of the
world's land mass it's difficult to
imagine but all that's nonsense all that
was nonsense was it
uh that may be a a second thing he was
thinking about but I think his the
interest of securing his personal power
is the most important for him also this
native it's not about need it's about
possible Western interference into
domestic affairs in order to instigate
protest because Putin and his
accomplices they are sure that all
protest within the country cannot just
be created by the people because they
are dissatisfied it's only uh it is only
orchestrated by the West so it's another
thing but the first reason is just to to
um to cement his his grip to power
does he want to fight with NATO
I hope not but you know he he put
himself in the situation where he has no
good exits and I think this black male
and threats is the only instrument he
may use to try to get himself out of
this
considering how you've denounced the war
and the lies of the Russian government
how worried are you about your own
safety
um I I don't really think about this
very much I believe that now we are
living in such dangerous time that we
all must think about the safety of the
humankind more than our individual says
so
that's that's my that's my answer
because I I know I don't think much
about that
a whole Spate of key figures businessmen
people in society who may or may not
have opposed the war have landed up dead
recently many seem to have had
unexpected accidents or jumped out of
upstairs Windows not a coincidence is it
there's a killing operation underway
isn't there in Russia yeah it's very
suspicious coincidences yes but I I have
no information about that I think all
these cases should be investigated of
course but once Putin is gone let me
come back to the issue of nuclear
weapons because several Western
officials among them America's national
security advisors say they've spelled
out to the Kremlin the exact
catastrophic consequences of going
nuclear
do you think in any way that will deter
Putin
you're in the arms control business
it's a well deterrence usually works
when both sides of all parties to this
negotiation to this
uh conversation both parties are
reasonable and they don't want to die
and of course they just want to uh to
keep your enemy adversary at the
distance
in this case Putin well is simulating
quite successfully that he is not quite
reasonable or maybe he is really
unreasonable we don't know so we can't
exclude that he may
command to to start the nuclear strikes
we don't know
so in this case if we deal with a man
who considers it that it is okay to
start a nuclear war then deterrence may
not work if Russia really intends to use
a nuclear weapon what would be the signs
to look out for do you get any of these
signs now do you see any of them signs
that Moscow is readying its nuclear
Arsenal for use
well I'm not the military expert to know
such technical details which could show
us that Moscow is really reading its
troops or nuclear strikes so I believe
that the intelligence gathered by the
Western countries is much more reliable
in this regardless and they say for now
that they detect no such signs
but
I just read that in her song obelisks
temporally occupied by Russians some
troops were
distributed to some you know radiation
radiation
appeals or something as if they were
being ready for nuclear strike I don't
know maybe it's just a protagonist
stand or something
so
I don't know the the rhetoric of Russian
leadership is still very aggressive and
the nuclear blackmail has been in place
since February 24th so if we judge by
territory we can say that they were
ready to nuclear strikes since the
beginning of the war but it's not so
evidently so whether they will be ready
to start the nuclear conflict that's
that's a big question that's a good
question it appears that some of the
Fail-Safe mechanisms designed to prevent
a nuclear war have in part been eroded
I'm talking about Direct Communications
between senior Russian and American
military leaders these appear to have
stopped how dangerous is that
it is it is very dangerous of course
because those uh those communication
channels have been very useful since the
Caribbean crisis and it okay is it
allowed to the key military commanders
to to talk directly with each other thus
decreasing the possibility of erupting
the war but of course in this current
situation when both sides are are not do
not trust the child so to speak
these channels may not just be working
and
so under those circumstances how easy
would it be for one side to misread the
signals of the other and launch a war on
a false understanding of the facts
it is very probable it is very probable
because Russian side I'm sure is very
very
um nervous about any possible signs of I
don't know attack or any other
interference from the Western Conference
first of all the United States into the
Ukrainian War so they can I don't know
what what what the red lines are but of
course they are some red lines so they
can be very well as we already seen the
Russian leadership has been very
inadequate since the invasion
so it's very hard to say how they
perceive the information they get it's
from the front lines from the NATO
countries so they can decide
something something very imaginable
without real real uh reasons for that
so the the risk of miscopulation misin
interpretation misunderstanding is very
high
so what you're saying is that this could
all get out of hand very quickly
um I would say that it can get out of
hands but also there are scenarios that
it won't
I think it is up to Native countries to
Native diploma so I don't know someone
from them to to start or maybe maintain
contacts with those
people in Russian Elite around and maybe
in second or third echelon of Russian
power to to present them that the Putin
is the only obstacle
begins with the normalization of
relations against this so Putin must be
gone with his closer close uh complexes
and then the situation may be like
reversed
then I think that may uh may push those
people to to Rally against Putin within
the within the government
so it's vital to try and keep as many
Communications open as possible
communication challenge yeah yeah sure
maybe not with Putin himself maybe if he
should be isolated from his supporters
that that's the word to split the
Russian Elite it's very important
Paris Pandora thank you very much for
being on conflict Zone it's good to see
you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]